ce
[Musique]
n'est pas la menace d'une guerre avec
l'ukraine qui ouvre les bulletins de
nouvelles de la chaîne principale en
russie aujourd'hui mais plutôt le 78ème
anniversaire de la levée du blocus de
leningrad du mot le président vladimir
poutine s'est recueillie seul et en
silence au pied du monument des victimes
on ne peut que deviner ce qu'il pense
il n'a pas dit un seul mot en public
depuis le 23 décembre sur cette crise
diplomatique qui militaire que le temps
l'accusent d'avoir provoqué en déployant
ses milliers de troupes à la frontière
de l'ukraine ni russe n'en savent pas
plus et suivent la balle au bond
il ya une sacrée tensions dans l'espace
médiatique d'un côté comme de l'autre
dit pavel petrov qui rentre à la maison
si la télévision d'état reprochent aux
américains et à l'otan de démoniser la
russie d'attiser les tensions en
brandissant le risque d'une invasion
l'ukraine nous les gens savent on lire
entre les lignes du juli sidorenko cause
de chacun a sa propre vérité ses propres
intérêts à défendre
nous avons les nôtres dit il mais rien
ne justifie la guerre
un accord n'est possible que si les
dirigeants agissent au nom de leurs
citoyens et c'est ce que le kremlin
affirme vouloir faire en revendiquant
sans aucun compromis possible l'arrêt de
l'expansion de l'otan tout comme le
retrait des troupes de l'alliance dans
les pays voisins réactions positives et
newt et à chapitre nous n'avons pas reçu
de réponse positive des états unis dit
le ministre sergueï lavrov même si la
lettre reçue de washington permet selon
lui d'espérer une discussion sérieuse
sur des questions secondaires
sont le plateau de cette émission
d'affaires publiques
le débat et ans appliquez la force ou
poursuivre le dialogue on cherche le
dialogue
l'animateur enterré par ses invités
alors que la russie publier à nouveau
des vidéos comme celle ci
où l'on voit des centaines de soldats
arrivés près de la frontière de
l'ukraine
j'ai peur c'est pourquoi je pars
rejoindre mes parents en italie dit
camila qui étudia
président vladimir poutine qui décidera
du prochain pas à franchir et il en
profite pour faire monter les enchères
le temps a décidé d'en faire autant en
préparant la riposte tout mouvement
diplomatique est désormais soumis à une
manifestation de force comme à l'époque
de la guerre froide et avec tous les
risques que ça comprend ici tamar
altérer ce coup radio-canada moscou